[Music]
Got it. You're like really hard. There
you go. Okay. And boom. And yeah, that
felt the whole target the whole time on
that punch.
That final thing is what you're doing in
mchous is you're checking his height and
it generates resistance to the ski and
now he can't ride the ski. Everything's
going to go into his body. Okay. Um so
we'll do a a we're going to take that
concept which you use all the time in
fighting. We're going to take it out of
makosh and then let's see if we can get
back to makosh. We have we have these
technique I me right
and that's exactly that he is being
checked. I feel his center. Do you see
that his energy is coming in? I check
his height and I hit into his center not
around his body. Okay. So when I drop my
hand, that is where the energy, the yong
aspect is brought to the ground. Okay?
And it's effortless.
And it feels like you're hitting a wall.
Okay, one more time. Just feels like a
wall.
What did it feel like when you got hit?
Do you know what I mean? Right. Run into
a wall. Yeah. It just feels like a wall.
Okay. Um
and that I know like uh There's also no,
just like the point you were made, the
principle you were making, there's no
way for me to slink my way around it or
bleed energy out. I'm also like I pop
off. Yes. Yeah. So, for example, I've
seen that done this way for a little
bit. It's not going to work. Okay. But
pretend it does work. But you you you
you see like this.
Do you know have you you know what I'm
talking about? And uh and then the guy
does the back break fall. The guy does
the back brake fall from there.
You see that? But you're that's setting
up that problem. Nothing is providing
resistance to the thrust. And so he he
would he could just run out. Okay. He
doesn't have to do that fall.
Do you guys see that? So it's like it
doesn't work because they don't
understand the concept of what how you
actually generate force at impact and
solve the problem that he has all these
hinges in his body and he's bipedal and
he could just walk out of all of this
stuff. Okay. Or try to yield off energy.
That's what real people do. Okay. All
right.